a full day coming up at the Los Angeles
Times festival of the book
Steve Wasserman is with us mr. Wasserman
what is your role in the festival and
what can people expect here
well a modestly I suppose I'd have to
confess that my role is a kind of salty
rock to the Republic of Letters here in
Los Angeles I along with my colleagues
at the Los Angeles Times are responsible
for the programming at the festival for
its editorial content and on a weekly
basis you do what a weekly basis I
preside over that weekly festival of
books known as the Los Angeles Times
Book Review and the book review despite
the economy going south everywhere else
my employers expanded it by a third a
year ago so it's very very healthy
despite the paucity of advertising shame
on the book publishing world they don't
know how many people love and read books
here in Los Angeles and celebrate the
written word why did your newspaper
begin this festival this festival was
begun eight years ago it was the mad
idea of a woman named art as a keynote
who had the odd idea that there were
quite a lot of people who would get off
their stairmasters and get up out of
their lap pools and come off the beach
for books and the first year they
expected maybe 25,000 people to show up
three times that number came today we
have probably an estimated 170,000
people attending it on this last weekend
in April in this upcoming panel
discussion you are going to moderate a
discussion on the topic of the day the
war in Iraq why have a pen like this
well the panel which will consist of
Christopher Hitchens who is the eye of
stone fellow at UC Berkeley's Graduate
School of Journalism and the author of
several books and of the of an upcoming
book about the war in Iraq and is
probably the finest polemicist of his
generation along with Robert Scheer
syndicated columnist for the Los Angeles
Times and Samantha power whose book a
problem from hell America in the age of
genocide has just won the Pulitzer Prize
and Mark Danner who also teaches at the
UC School of Journalism at Berkeley and
contributes to the New Yorker in the New
York Review of Books
well what could be more timely than to
engage this complicated set of issues
which sees the United States taking an
unprecedented
role in the affairs of the Middle East
there have been a lot of panels like
this what are you going to try to make
this one different well we're going to
try to explore insofar as we're humanly
capable without the usual jargon in the
posturing with a degree of sobriety and
seriousness and level of conversation
that goes against the grain of the
coarseness that too often deforms debate
on these issues in this country
Steve Wasserman thank you very much
we're going to take you inside this
building right here Haynes hall for the
panel discussion on Iraq
before introducing our panelists each of
whom will make introductory remarks of
about five minutes in duration each then
there'll be some rebuttal and we'll have
an exchange after that before
introducing them let me make a few
remarks this debate this discussion this
exploration of issues that have attached
themselves like so many barnacles to one
of the most difficult and thorny
questions before the Republic is
entitled American power and the war in
Iraq the hour that we have before us
is too brief a time of course to explore
in the depth that is truly required to
explore the many issues that have
pressed themselves so painfully and so
acutely on the citizens of this country
and indeed on citizens in nations all
over the globe but we will do our best
to raise questions and to do what we can
to challenge received opinion to examine
shibboleths and canards and to in some
fashion get at the truth of what is
reported to us and what we have
experienced over the past number of
months and indeed to try to explore in
some interesting fashion what is
unfolding before us and likely to unfold
before us in the coming months and
arguably years to come the United States
and its coalition partner Great Britain
are in Mesopotamia having for the moment
one the brief 28-day war in about half
the time as it took to expel Saddam
Hussein's troops from the occupation of
Kuwait 12 or 13 years ago
the regime of Saddam Hussein is no more
and one would have to possess a heart of
stone not to have been stirred by many
of the pictures that were beamed to us
to see the palpable relief on the faces
of the people who had been for many
decades ground down and under by a
despotic regime whose murderous intents
have now been revealed to all of us
whether or not of course the course set
by the Bush administration was both
justified and wise still imposes itself
upon us and is and continues to be worth
debating and thinking about particularly
as events are moving with great rapidity
and it seems clear that the United
States principally has managed to
accomplish what the Iranian regime in
the aftermath of the toppling of the
Shah so signally failed to do which is
to remove from power a secular thug and
to permit a process of rearrangement in
a country whose history is very brief
after all it perhaps is germane to point
out that the history of the Bechtel
corporation is far longer one than even
the modern state of Iraq
let us begin with the proposition that
this course was both justified and wise
and let us try to ask the question can
the piece be kept can it be constructed
is it wise to do so are there larger
principles at work having to do with
unilateral preemption and the rule of
law and let us think about those
questions with as much sobriety as we
can muster and and to free ourselves of
as much rhetoric and Kant as we are
humanly capable of that process and that
debate has been too rare in a culture
which has largely coarsened discussion
of these important issues
let me introduce first Christopher
Hitchens who is the if' stone fellow at
the UC Berkeley Graduate School of
Journalism a columnist for Vanity Fair
and arguably one of the most gifted
polemicists of his generation
Oh aye he points out that I've neglected
to mention that he's the author of many
books including a book which you have
yet to read but which is at the press
now entitled the long short war the
postponed liberation of Iraq which will
be in bookstores throughout the country
on June 9th thank you Steve
sorry for the prompt I guess thank you
for the arguably as well good morning
good a good day ladies and gentlemen
thank you for coming
brothers and sisters comrades and
friends this feels like Groundhog Day to
me I think this is the third or fourth
time that I've appeared with some
version of this panel on this subject
though I'm glad to say that today
instead of the impossibly handsome and
laconic features of michael ignatieff we
have instead the impossibly tempestuous
features of Samantha power so I feel to
that extent redeemed from the groundhog
condemnation Christos Anesti to any of
you who happened to be Greek and
celebrating Easter today I want to begin
at an oblique angle to the subject on
Thursday last the partition line of
barbed wire and rubble that has
separated the Greek and Turkish peoples
of Cyprus by a full-fledged NATO
occupation colonization and semi
annexation by Turkey for now upwards of
a quarter of a century that it imposed a
completely apartheid colonial system on
the people of Cyprus who was the result
of a coup in an invasion both of them
the brainchild of mr. Henry Kissinger
this border fell down hasn't been
reported yet in the local media it seems
to me I've been looking for reports of
it
I've come I know much more about the
Peterson family than I ever wanted to
know but nothing about the extraordinary
fact that the last divided capital city
in the world and the last one in Europe
Nicosia is divided no more it seems that
the Turkish authorities on Thursday in
the sense surrendered they gave up they
said the border is open Greek Cypriots
who I never have been going back to
homes they thought they would never see
again and trying to recover cultural
treasures that they thought were
irretrievably lost and even more
heartening ly many Turkish Cypriots are
making their way south to apply for
Cyprus identity cars redefining their
nationality as Cypriot not as Turkish or
as products of a Turkish colonial
occupation and wanting a share in the
future Europe of which Cyprus Greek and
Turkish is about to become a member I
think that this is indissoluble this
wonderful moment extraordinary moment of
liberation equally comparable if not
more so to the fall of the Berlin Wall
as the recent Ozymandias events in
paradise square in the centre of Baghdad
that would qualify to be I believe this
to be indiscernible from what all of us
in the campaign for the liberation of
Iraq hopes and believed would be true
that by the the inauguration of this
process a positive wind of change would
indeed begin to blow throughout that
region it's very clear to me that the
Turkish government realizing that it has
failed to prevent the emancipation of
Iraq failing even to profit here from it
by making an opportunistic move into
Kurdistan failing even to accept the
bribe that was offered to uphold its own
interests by our national security
establishment has been forced to make an
essential concession and has begun to
retreat from its policy of isolationism
colonialism in military expansionism
this is an extraordinarily important
fact especially when you remember that
when we were last met we have this panel
about a month ago it was confidently
predicted on all sides that Turkey would
seize the territory of northern Iraq
would put an end to the experiment in
Kurdish self-rule and autonomy would
project its power under the American
umbrella deep into Iraq that was only
one of the many ridiculous doom-laden
predictions that one had to combat to
the contrary the ratchet of emancipation
works in the opposite direction Kurdish
autonomy one of the most important
causes of the movement for international
human rights that there is the largest
minority in the world there are just
people in the world that don't have a
state their autonomy in northern Iraq is
now further guaranteed underwritten and
expanded and it's been met with his
counterpart in Cyprus it was also
predicted about a month ago with even
more confidence that general Sharon
would seize this opportunity to cleanse
the West Bank of its remaining
Palestinian inhabitants and complete the
process of ethnic cleansing this too
would be an unfailing consequence of any
attempt to end the use by Saddam Hussein
of Iraq as his own personal torture
chamber well that didn't happen either
if our general Charan now is having to
have a much more serious discussion
about his illegal colonial settlements
than he's ever had to have with any
previous United States administration
and this - it seems to me as the
counterpart is one of the other shoes
that is dropping at the realization that
there is nothing stable as well as
nothing decent in a policy that relies
on proxy rule on client states and on
fascistic regimes it's a great moment in
fragile one that everyone should be
proud of that the United States has
begun to discard the policy of the proxy
state and the client regime and has
begun to say that whatever the risks
democracy is more stable and as well as
more justifiable as an experiment I
think that's a moment every American
ought to be very pleased about and
pleased with and the fact of the matter
is by what an exercise of warrants Hagel
once called I'll plagiarize him for a
second the cunning of history the United
States has found itself at war with the
forces of reaction I'll say it again so
you can relish it the United States has
found itself by perhaps an exercise of
the cunning of history at war with the
forces of reaction this policy of regime
change was opposed by the Saudi Arabian
or agog the people who helped to bring
us al-qaeda was opposed by the Pakistani
secret police and the dictatorship that
helped
bring us the Taliban unalterably opposed
to the policy of regime change it was
opposed by the Turkish establishment
with its perennial adventures in Cyprus
and its projected colonial adventures in
Kurdistan it's a challenge to what's
long been an insufferable status quo and
I know I'm not gonna need to rehearse
for you
the exhilarating effect that has had for
all the people of Iraq obviously now if
you want to get your story into the New
York Times or The Washington Post or the
LA Times you have to know where to put
the apostrophe and the word shear or
Shiite they happen to be the story at
the moment this too is part of the long
list of doom-laden predictions that I
think will turn out to be false and will
be falsified there is of course a moment
of revolution among the sheer population
of Iran but we haven't heard from
innumerable other elements of that
population yet including the four
million with four million out of twenty
to twenty three million Iraqis gifted
talented professional qualified and
democratic who've been forced by this
horrendous regime to live outside their
own country and who can now return
bringing their skills and their
experience of living in a democratic
society it's with these people we should
be working those people who won't have
time for many more mass anti-war
demonstrations maybe wondering what to
do with the time of relying so heavily
on their hands from now on why have some
suggestions they could raise some money
to help the people who are restarting
the Free Press in Baghdad they could
raise some money for the human rights
groups who are going to be digging up
the mass graves and breaking up in the
secret prisons and tearing open the
torture chambers they could sponsor the
families of some of the thousands and
tens of thousands of missing Iraqis and
Kurds who are getting want help finding
their families or finding at least what
happened to them there's going to be
plenty of work for everybody to do and I
think it's high time that the the
American human rights community helped
to put a rock at the top of its list of
priorities in that respect one more
minute I'll just make two closing points
there if I've only 60 seconds in 1990
the reason why my book is called the
long short war and the reason I wanted
it to be introduced under that title is
that what we've just seen is not the end
of a 28 day war at the end of a 13 year
one which began in 1990 when Saddam
Hussein actually abolish
existence of a neighboring Arab and
Muslim state annexed Kuwait entirely to
Iraq in in the year 1990 he had a choice
he could either invade Kuwait before or
just after he acquired a nuclear weapon
which the inspectors had then failed to
find they didn't find his nuclear
weaponry until afterwards the only soft
criticisms that I was saying has ever
made in his entire life is to say I
probably should have finished work on
the nuke before I took over the heard of
Kuwait that's how self-critical he can
be on a good day well now he hasn't got
Kuwait and he hasn't got the bomb and
he's never going to find out what it's
like to have weapons of mass destruction
he did make an alliance with the forces
of jihad openly openly appealing to them
openly training them the bin Laden list
forces in Kurdistan and in southern and
central we found them they were almost
the only people willing to fight for him
so we know the terror connection is
proved because that that alliance
between them didn't start the day before
yesterday come race I can promise you
that and we will though it's taken 13
years 13 years far too long 12 of those
years really were eaten by the locust in
Iraq finally the job is very nearly
completed and all it remains for me to
recommend I think in closing is that we
give them the inspections more time
thank you
in the interest of maximizing the amount
of time that each panelist will have I
respectfully ask each of them to remain
at their current posts let me introduce
to you mark
Danner who is a professor of
international relations at UC Berkeley's
Graduate School of Journalism the author
of Ella's the massacre at el mozote a an
extraordinary work of investigative
reportage about the depredations that
occurred in Central America in the early
80s he is also the author of a
forthcoming book called the saddest
story America of the Balkans and the
post-cold war world he's a contributor
to the New York Review of Books mark
Danner
thank you Steve thank you for coming
this is indeed a Groundhog Day moment
Christopher and I have shared this stage
now I think this is the third time and I
am profoundly sad that I have thus far
apparently failed to convince him of my
arguments but today he will have a
further choice are a further opportunity
to be convinced he said that the work is
nearly completed in Iraq and I would say
that this is definitely not the end it's
not the end of the beginning it's not
the beginning of the end excuse me and
it is perhaps perhaps near the end of
the beginning
we've perhaps reached that we're at the
beginning of an occupation we are at the
beginning of a political project that
must as we always knew follow the
military project and it leaves in front
of us two main questions can the United
States establish a lasting stable
democratic political order in Iraq that
is favorable to American interests and
second the wind the the lovely wind that
Christopher spoke about where will that
wind blow next that is what are the
implications for American foreign policy
and America's role in the world of the
Iraqi intervention and of the other
interventions that are currently being
discussed at the highest levels of
government privately and I would say in
recent days very very publicly I think
we are all blessed and that we're living
in a plastic time that is things are
changing things are being reshaped it
happened first after the first world war
with the decision of the United States
not to join the League of Nations second
in the late 40s when the institutions of
NATO Marshall Plan the United Nations
and others were set up by which the
United States led a struggle against the
Soviet Union for half a century as
leader of an alliance system and it's
happening now again
where you see the United States
essentially demolishing a good deal of
that alliance system and a good deal of
that multilateral system and changing to
the politics of unilateralism hegemonic
unilateral and very much reliant on
military force the question before all
of us and the one that we can the answer
to which we can follow every day in our
newspapers presumably on the front page
perhaps on the inside pages is can the
United States establish a new order in
the vacuum that it is created in Iraq
the dictatorship has been destroyed a
national security state that for 30
years has dominated the politics of Iraq
that has either exported or killed
political competition and political
opposition it no longer exists there is
to some degree a tabula rasa but there
are political elements that we have
already seen come to the fore in recent
days and that I would wager will come
much more to the fore in the next weeks
one is the Shia's structure of politics
on the ground which has already had for
the first time in 30 years its yearly
pilgrimage to Karbala and has already
begun staging demonstrations in the
capital and elsewhere against the United
States we have an Iraq a situation
similar to that for all its differences
in Haiti after 1986 and in other
countries we can think of after the end
of despotism that is a new political
universe is being born
we have planets suns constellations
wheeling off into space
we'll have newspapers we'll have
political parties we'll have political
groupings
we'll have alliances and each of these
political groupings will be trying to
gain to look for lucrative political
issues in the United States very quickly
has already actually become the main
political issue in the country that is
we're trying to create a democracy a
democratic system or at least we say we
are under the shadow the inevitable
shadow of nationalism it is as if we're
trying to do delicate work under our own
in the darkness and that shadow of
nationalism will become more and more
prominent I think in the days and weeks
ahead the key problem in the Middle East
which we're going to confront I think
and the problem raised by Christopher's
talk is if indeed we have been over the
years for democracy in the Middle East
why are there no democracies there and
since there are no democracies there why
is it that we support and have continued
to support
autocracies both by your tax dollars for
military defense of the regime in the
Gulf the regime in Saudi Arabia or by
direct foreign aid in the case of Egypt
as well as other places three billion
dollars a year and the answer to that I
think is rather simple which is that the
autocratic rulers of those states are
favorable to American interests or at
least appear to be so and the people
increasingly are not we are about to
confront that issue in that paradox in
all its glory in Iraq that is if the
democratic order that we claim we
support and that we claim to want to
create is indeed created it risks very
much being an order that will be
anti-american and certainly
anti-american policy in the Middle East
and with respect especially to Israel
and the Palestinians a few days ago
Donald Rumsfeld simply said when asked
what if a Shiite regime takes power
contrary to American interests he simply
laid down the line that will not happen
again there's an obvious paradox there
when we talk about our deep our ideas
about democracy
I will prophesy that in the next weeks
and months we will have incidents
involving American troops who must be in
the role of enforcing security in Iraq
involving demonstrations involving other
security matters that will make the
United States front and center the main
political interest in that the main
political issue in the nascent politics
of that country one of the surprising
things
over the past weeks has been well among
other things there were no flowers and
sweets greeting us in the streets but
the second excuse me most surprising
thing it seems to me is that the United
States was very unprepared for the
occupation itself and that a number of
decisions that had to be made before it
most obviously how the country would be
secured how Americans would protect
public buildings how Americans would
apply security in the main cities and
finally what political order America
would support what would be its policy
for example toward the Iraqi National
Congress and Ahmed Chalabi those
questions were not resolved within the
government they're still being fought
over we will see now the cost of this
indecision I think we'll also see the
costs of the fact that the Pentagon is
going to run this occupation and the
political mastermind Donald Rumsfeld it
seems will be the public face of this
occupation the Pentagon is not known for
its political sophistication it is known
for its military prowess and that the
United Nations partly as a result of the
wounds that still remain from the
pre-war diplomatic fight is going to be
kept out of things so we see the
continuing cost of this struggle thank
you mark and now we'll turn to Samantha
let me introduce Samantha power a
professor at the Kennedy School of
Government and a founder of the Carr
Center for human rights at Harvard
University and the author of an
indispensable volume on our current
predicament
both the recent past the present and the
likely future called a problem from hell
America in the age of genocide for which
she was just awarded the Pulitzer Prize
I don't know I still want to hear those
words it sounds about as unfamiliar as
being told I've just won the siyoung
a lot of people ask because one of the
chapters of the book is on the
atrocities that Christopher went and
explored firsthand in northern Iraq in
the genocide that stomm committed
against the Kurds the gassing the
destruction of the villages the
attempted eradication of rural Kurds in
northern Iraq and 87-88
how it could be that I could have been
so skeptical about this war and so I
just like to begin by sketching sort of
some of the reasons I think all of which
raise questions not only about the
future of Iraq but also as Marcus
suggested about the future of American
power and also crucially and something
that we all have to take into account
the future of international institutions
because we seem to fall prey to a kind
of romanticizing impulse when it comes
to international institutions I think
those of us who experience the Bosnia
conflict should should be wary of but
that's what happens when one ends up so
skeptical about the motives and the
plans of the administration the first
reason of course to be skeptical about
the war and was just the loss of life
and here it can be grateful that it was
mercifully quick I do think that we all
fall prey to a tendency to kind of write
off
deaths to Iraqi soldiers on the grounds
that they are illegitimate combatants
but I think again one of the questions
this war raises and any war against
theocratic fascism or dictatorship or
whatever does raise our the forces of
reaction is when soldiers are gang
pressed often into service should we be
so consoled when the tens of thousands
of lives lost are those of soldiers so I
just think it's a question worth raising
and that's still with us second point
and this I think is really challenging
for all of us is you know again there
was a genocide committed by this man
I mean if not there than where it seems
to me from a human rights standpoint and
I'm not Michael Ignatieff but this was I
think the argument that he made sitting
in this in this spot a month ago I felt
that that the danger and this is just
sounds like parsing but that was not a
mortal danger and nor an immediate
danger to the Kurds or to citizens of
Iraq and I'm sure Christopher will weigh
in on this later but that there was an
argument that could be made for a
punitive intervention twelve years later
there was an argument for preventive
intervention because God knows once one
has committed acts like that one is
capable of doing it again but that
without the mortal immediate threat to
life your default toward multilateral
sanction should remain in place
in other words toward that requirement
and so this is intense formalism though
and I think those of us who wanted you
know a UN Security Council resolution
quietly blinded ourselves to the lunacy
of having Russia and China be the
arbiters of our principles when it comes
to human rights and I don't think I
don't think we take that fact very
seriously and I think as while we we we
have good reason for turning to the
Security Council because they are the
only guardians of legitimate so-called
legitimate and/or legal action they are
the only guardians of our order and so
we it's one-stop shopping it's the only
place to go but I did there is a tension
built into this when it comes to
actually them being the determinants of
when that direct and mortal and
immediate threat is actually opposed
thirdly we of course had great
skepticism about the human rights
motives of individuals within this
administration now of course the chapter
in my book that is on Iraq documents how
many of the officials who made today's
policy were in fact of course famously
legendarily aligned with Saddam at the
time that he was using chemical weapons
against his own people and indeed our
generous aid package to his regime which
was 500 million dollars a year in
agricultural credits in 1988 while the
genocide was being carried out was
actually doubled the year
after to more than a billion dollars in
agricultural credit so I think one could
be forgiven at being quite skeptical
despite the sort of conversion ethos in
Washington around morality and human
rights and freedom and even
nation-building that one was sort of
worried about how if in the
scratch-and-sniff model how deep these
commitments actually sort of went now
again in terms of what that leaves us
with today I think we can still one of
the reasons by the way to be concerned
about motives is that is not for
epistemological reasons or because good
intention is a priori you know the only
thing that one can look for in order to
judge good results and and or even in
the end retrospectively even it may be a
just war not in the traditional Just War
theory of course but it's that it
actually tells you a lot people's
motives tell you a lot about the means
that they're going to employ as Mark
we're saying the priorities that they're
gonna make as the as the war itself is
being conducted and of course the
capacity for follow-through and the
tenor of follow-through so you look to
motives actually more as a proxy for
what you're going to see later now the
good news potentially is that because
weapons are proving kind of hard to find
the the the the human rights and the
freedom argument has from day one really
it was announced as Operation Iraqi
Freedom
not Operation Iraqi disarmed and the
fewer weapons one finds the more the
freedom argument becomes the
retrospective justification of course
for the war and it was a factor it has
to be said it was one factor among
several but it was a small factor and I
don't think there's anyone in the
administration who would have said I
mean Christopher would be the person who
would say it was the genocide alone that
normatively that you know should have
sent us there but I don't think there's
anybody even the most sort of freedom
spewing members of this administration
who would say with a straight face that
it was simply because of that that we
went there so we have this this issue
though that that now it is at the
centerpiece of American rhetoric and
retrospective justification it may
remain that but let's ask the question
of maybe that can do some good maybe
there is now some cognitive dissonance
that can be experienced by members of
this administration as they continue to
conduct business as usual with other
repressive regimes and and I do think
also to Mark's point about
follow-through it is going to get harder
and harder we were talking about this
yesterday to lose face and to do the
hit-and-run version of nation-building
which of course has been the American
temptation in both Afghanistan and in
the Balkans so I think that one walk one
could be very skeptical about the
rhetoric coming out of the
administration
it actually has entailed an investment
of American credibility and prestige it
may be an investment that we can figure
out a way to spin our way out of
eventually when the costs become too
high but I think that one has to look
perhaps to some ripple effect on other
policies with other repressive regimes
and demand it of course and then just
two more points in closing one of the
other questions of the reasons that we
were skeptic of course was this point
about a fear of staying power power in
in Iraq you know would we just go in
maybe you know do regime change get out
leave the Iraqi people to their fate
having long privileged order over
justice where we're now going to go in
you know get our version of order
attended to and leave disorder to
prevail in the country here is very
tricky of course because the
administration is such a balancing act
now because on the one hand they can't
stay too long because that's just
confirmation of all the worst motives of
Empire and land grab and oil grab and
all the rest on the other hand they
can't leave tomorrow because then
they'll be subject to the understandable
criticism that they've opened up this
Pandora's box and the left people to
their own devices so I think we all have
to ask ourselves question now that the
deed has been done and we have inherited
this mess exactly how do we get this
balance right sort of like Goldilocks
you know you can't stay too long you
can't stay too short what is you know
that that period that is the right
period where we can actually hand off
again I want to stress though we are
very prone to romanticize both the
United Nations as a sort of peacekeeping
enforcement force and other member
states who themselves believe me if they
could have gotten that Bechtel contract
they too would have made a lunge in that
direction
so we come back again and again to some
very structural problems in the
international order in terms of states
being the guardians of the principles
that we think that we hold dear and then
finally and I hope if we get more time
to talk more about this but the main
reason that I came down altom Utley it
plunked as Michael Walter says against
the war was just the fear that while it
would make Iraq a more humane place that
it would make the world a much more
dangerous place and I don't think that
we have grappled with the way that we
have forfeited our legitimacy as the
guardians of these principles and and I
think this administration is committed
to the idea that it's more important to
be feared than to be liked and I would
just say that the strength of American
history is actually a testament to the
fact that it's much more important to be
respected than to be either feared or
liked it's nice to you you being feared
is important and the use of hard power
is an essential part of this war on
terrorism but to minimize the value of
America's so-called soft power and its
ability to make others want what we want
I think is to is to really lose sight of
recent history and right now people want
to want what we don't want and that's
dangerous thank you
I'd like to introduce now Robert Scheer
the USC clinical professor at the USC
Annenberg School for Communication the
author of numerous books including
America after Nixon the age of the
multinationals with enough shovels
Reagan Bush and nuclear war and the
serious but somewhat mischievous Lee
titled book thinking tunafish talking
death essays on the pornography of power
and a syndicated columnist for the Los
Angeles Times
every time a institution is connected
with my name they want to fire me so my
connection with USC is great ten years I
teach a class I'm a syndicated columnist
so fortunately the LA Times runs I thank
them I don't speak for them or USC or
anyone else even my own wife disagrees
with me
profoundly so I just want to be clear
about that I will also learn from these
exchanges that it takes a great deal of
courage to support the administration if
you're in the media and it's an act of
cowardliness to criticize the
administration I learned us in our last
debate I've learned this from the
thousands of emails that I get and I
just want to disabuse people I am NOT
Islamic fanatic and that was not the
reason for my criticizing the war
however clearly our panel here is
unexpectedly unbalanced I thought we
would have more of an administration
point of view so I would like to take
that position and and say we said that
we have to go against Sarah was saying
because after all we've been attacked in
the most devious attack of September
11th and we couldn't be indifferent to
it and we fortunately have this ally of
Pakistan that some people had been
behind the Taliban and al-qaida but we
wanted to see spawning them for their
nuclear weapons so he dropped the
sanctions and we needed them so we
couldn't be mean with the Pakistanis and
we certainly couldn't be mean with the
Saudis even though 15 of the hijackers
came from Saudi Arabia because we get
along so well with them and they play
ball with us and so what did we have we
had Simon was saying and we had
fortunately bulletproof evidence to use
donilon's knows words bulletproof I
don't know what bulletproof means to you
but me I would think it's a pretty
strong case that Saddam Hussein was
behind September 11th night that's
behind some terrorists you find in the
u.s. patrolled area of Iraq
down by Iran but behind Sodom upstairs
behind and since it would be an act of
disloyalty according to people like
O'Reilly and others to question the
administration let me tell you I expect
Donald Rumsfeld to produce that
bulletproof evidence just at any hour
and an hour applauded for it and I must
tell you every single weekend now I have
spent the weekend looking for weapons of
mass destruction because every single
weekend there is a story on CNN or
somewhere else that they've been found
and they're going to be tested and
they're gonna be proved and in fact for
all respect one passed for the New York
Times this is what Judith Miller said
last Monday then I read New York Times
on Tuesday what were they where are
those little Corrections or something
Wednesday oh well they weren't there but
there was a guy cited and they may have
had some chemicals that are and now the
current theory seems to be we'll never
find them but they're in the minds of
those things you could find in any
search on the internet you can find all
the ideas in fact the guy who did the
anthrax in Washington when we've all
forgotten about was evidently using us
materials and probably as part of our
defense establishment however having
said that I still think we'll find these
weapons of mass destruction because the
president says so as recently as
yesterday and it would be unpatriotic to
suggest that the president might be
lying to us because we live in a
democracy that we want to be the model
of the world so why would the president
lied to us when he's building a model
for the entire world it would not make
sense at all then we have the real
weapons of mass destruction the nuclear
ones the ones we no longer care that
Pakistan has and others and okay that
was a harder case to make because
nuclear weapons is you know can pretty
easily be detected and so forth to give
off all kinds of signals that you have
to get a lot of equipment you know do it
in your kitchen these other weapons but
fortunately we were able to find the
properly forged documents to make the
case and when you're up against a
particularly evil enemy you have to
forge documents that's
one of the things you do and I disagree
what Hans Blix that are sort of
surprising that our CIA and the British
intelligence did not know that these
were crude forgeries I think these
people are trained to not notice crude
fraud juries and as a result they just
passed it on as our own work and so
forth so the nuclear weapons issue
I'm sure again we will find there's this
massive cache and I looked at today
again but they didn't show up they are
the other thing that we have about this
whole question of our posture and the
model because let's face it there's a
serious point to be made here you don't
take over these countries unilaterally
and not have a responsibility I think
that's the point that was made whether
we like it or not we are in this thing
that george w bush condemned nation
building okay and if we don't do the
nation-building we're gonna be lots of
al-qaida's because that's what happened
in afghanistan we supported the
Mujahideen we said these were freedom
fighters Ronald Reagan had a day of
celebration every year for the freedom
fighters freedom fighters morphed into
the Taliban Taliban morphed into
al-qaeda they didn't like us so much and
we have this problem so we know it is no
walking away from Iraq and also we
committed what I think for colonialists
as a cardinal sin we actually said these
people are important you know they're
not just going to be house servants but
they're going to be democratic and their
rights are important and heresy of
heresies they should actually control
their own oil and it should be used for
their betterment this is the most
radical notion of the last 50 years at
the resources of these countries should
be used for the betterment of the people
my god if you apply that to Oakland or
Los Angeles you're really going to have
revolution here so they're there there
is no easy walking away from that and
and so then the question really becomes
absolutely critical
what model of democracy and again we I
think we've set a very good example
we've said the model democracy that
works and I think this is what Rumsfeld
whirring to when he said if they vote
for this kind of Islamic state forget it
and
have it the model of democracy were
advocating is we always vote correctly
and if you don't then you fudge a few
votes and and when in Florida and then
your president or as please don't clap
because then my friend Hitchens so I've
known for many years will accuse me of
throwing red meat to the Marvin and you
know people supporting your argument
means your argument is invalid I learned
that from our last debate but one more
minute
okay but I think that the critical thing
here the critical lesson is what really
was the lesson this is a country that
once believed in the League of the world
UN and everything I think goes to the
previous point we said that we can smash
the United Nations we can smash
multilateralism we could smash that
vision of the New World Order the
expanding NATO and everything because
they did not vote our way on our
timetable we wouldn't even allow Chile
through 30 days okay even when France
was crumbling and said give us 30 days
and what do we hear now instead of the
president united states saying hey
France a democratic country Germany's
Democrat country even Russia I looked in
Putin's eyes very honest man he was
elected I love him they disagree with us
hey that's how it works sometimes in
democracy you don't carry everybody
along sometimes even decent
well-informed people in the French
believe me know a lot about colonialism
they had Algeria in Vietnam they had
their cafes bombed they know this stuff
quite well Colin Powell even in his book
said if he'd read burnout fall he never
would have gone to Vietnam so they knew
something about the previous mistakes
but here you have a situation where the
president knighted States instead of
saying that said these people are there
the old regime they're out of the debate
the UN Security Council is not worth
anything because it's not going to vote
our way we won't even go for another
vote what are you saying about democracy
we are saying basically you're for
democracy when it comes out in support
of your interests you're skewed view at
that moment and I think the United
States has said the worst example and
has beat reeved the most important ideal
in this world you know which is that
people are allowed to debate these
things they should
be informed there should not be deceived
the government should speak truthfully
of him and instead we've had a
government that has lied to them far
more effectively than I've been able to
do playing the government role just
Thank You bus Thank You mr. chair
we'll now have a few minutes each for
rebuttals Krister well you might as well
laugh now because he went laughs at the
end I haven't got any mirthful stuff to
give you um let's see
Monsieur Chirac and Herr Schroeder both
said openly publicly and several times
that under no circumstances first would
they ever vote to employ force against
Saddam Hussein under no circumstances
and on the production of no evidence and
second that under no circumstances would
the policies of their countries
respectively France and Germany be
determined by the United Nations in
other words the really selfish
unilateral irresponsible lawless powers
were the ones threatening to use their
vetoes with that mentality in that way
the demand for extra time would have
brought us into something like may next
month that's to say where the month that
Iraq was due to take the chair of the
United Nations Special Committee on
disarmament I'm now glad that it's Iraq
Stern next month I'm not so sure of
other people who wanted it to happen
when that would have been saddam hussein
in the chair of the UN Commission on
disarmer but that's what those who
wanted more time were touring for the
other thing more time would have given
would be the chance to buy a nuclear
weapon off the shelf from Kim Jong Il in
North Korea who I know I think will not
be going into that open market with
quite the same insouciance that he
proposed to do so before but that was
that was the axis as it would have
existed had action not been taken and
those who are opposed to this war who
ever stand up away they adopt their
position have simply to explain what
they proposed to do about the
Intolerable that he of the previous the
pre-existing status quo and I've
indicated just some of what those
consequences would have been now I
should say that everyone makes a great
play of their misgivings and their
second thoughts and so on it would be
unfair I think I hope they don't mean to
imply that those of us who take a
decided position don't understand the
nature of a misgiving
of course those of us who took the side
of the regime change policy knew what
the risks were of factional strife in
Iraq of intervention opportunist
interventions by neighboring countries
but all of those things were in Iraq's
future in any case if the regime had
been allowed to run its course and
choose the time and means of its own
expiry can you imagine how immiseration
the Iraqis would be now look what Saddam
Hussein did to his people in the short
time remaining to him forcing people
into the frontline on penalty of having
their tongues cut out importing jihad
forces from all over the region to do
his fighting for him training a special
black shirted force if his review being
allowed to run its course and continue
to be able to threaten the oil fields of
neighboring countries as well as of Iraq
itself there would have been a
nightmarish end to this it's not we
don't choose between keeping Iraq the
way it was and intervening Iraq was
already melting down and constituting a
danger to itself and others and there's
never any sense of the acceptance of
this responsibility in the rhetoric of
any of the critics of the policy it may
well be that it may well be it certainly
is it would be predicted by anybody a
resurgence of theocratic politics among
the Shia it has to be noticed however
that in Iran the major shear country in
the world a country between 65 and 70
million people the Tennessee is all the
other way they've tried running their
country out of a holy book and they
found out what happens when you try it
cannot be done the sheer revolution the
ayatollahs revolution in Iran is it
admitted failure and most of its people
want to be rid of it so that's what I
say well not mean when I say that the
wind of change blows in both directions
yes there are reactionary and unwelcome
consequences but there is a definite
tendency towards political reform and
the the most encouraging other
development in the region is clearly the
emergence of a civil society opposition
in Iran itself which it again I insist
should be the business of the so-called
left and auntie Ward Human Rights forces
to support to endorse to encourage
instead of endlessly sneering about that
would be my proposal
now it is certain he's he's beyond doubt
that Iraq at one point had extensive
nuclear chemical biological and other
weapons programs that's beyond doubt
nobody disputes it the nuclear reactor
was only discovered after the
intervention in Iraq in 1991 and that we
only discovered that way
how near Saddam Hussein came to the
threshold of joining the Kim Jong Il
Club why did we discover it earlier
because Hans Blix had certified that
Iraq was exemplary in its compliance
with the non-proliferation treaty that's
why we didn't discover it earlier in the
same way as Hans Blix s certified North
Korea repeatedly in the 1990s as in full
compliance with the non-preferred
proliferation treaty excuse me if I
don't take the word of dr. Blake
seriously at all and we know we know
from the tapes shown by secretary Powell
to the United Nations we certainly know
this much those inspection teams had
been penetrated as some of their members
turned to the Iraqis knew where the
inspections were coming and when the
process had become insulting it had been
degraded and corrupted I know myself so
I want to see very senior inspector who
was offered a personal bribe of a
million dollars by Tareq Aziz in person
in his office and not everyone said no
evidently if it turns out that Iraq has
destroyed or did in the closing days of
the Saddam Hussein regime destroy its
chemical and biological weapons stocks
which I hope they were smart enough to
do then that's one up for those of us
who said well if you don't destroy them
we're going to come and destroy them for
you I'm sorry the irony is not at our
expense if Iraq has disarmed it proves
our point and if it was at anyone's
expense it would be at those who told me
repeatedly in the run-up to this
intervention that if it took place
Saddam Hussein would obliterate Israel
and other neighboring countries with
chemical and biological weapons they
told me that's what would happen if he
was challenged well do they fear any
sense of embarrassment and the apparent
fact that Iraq is at any rate
appreciably nearer to being disarmed
than it was before this is no time for
witless sneering on that point either I
think that's all I'll say for now thank
you
mark mark Danner one thing that remains
constant between the debate a month and
a half ago and now is that we're still
arguing about inspections apparently and
we're still wondering when the weapons
of mass destruction will be will be
found you see a tendency on the part of
the administration now to redefine the
issue and say in fact the president the
other night to NBC News said we will
certainly find that they had the means
to make these weapons I suspect we will
find that but I'm not sure how much it
serves us to debate here about
inspections I think it's very clear as
Samantha noted that there were a number
of different reasons for the war that
when we talk about governments or when
we talk about the Bush administration
even though we tend to personify it and
say it does this because we're in fact
talking about a great number of people
especially those at the top who tend to
be very aggressive and strong-willed and
who fight with one another and we're
looking at a political synthesis that
ends up bringing you a particular action
and it was clear there were national
security reasons that descend from the
Carter doctrine about the security of
the Persian Gulf and our need for oil
was clear there are many people who were
worried about weapons of mass
destruction the capability to build them
if that and then there were other people
who had this vision of democracy in the
Middle East the interesting thing now
and the reason why we are all lucky to
be sentient citizens in this moment of
history sentient American citizens is we
are seeing in front of us those
differences worked out there is a
jostling in the administration and a
jostling that will become more and more
violent as this occupation continues and
the interesting thing will be the kinds
of stresses that Samantha mentioned the
stresses between those who will be happy
having gotten rid of him and will
essentially want to wash their hands of
the
those who truly believe - probably the
growing astonishment of their more
cynical colleagues that democracy can be
installed in Iraq and others who have
their own reasons for making this
intervention my interest we can argue I
think about the French we can argue
about the Germans we can argue about the
effects of these debates but it seems to
me that again as citizens what we should
be concerned about is how this
occupation will develop and what it will
lead to I tried to give a sense in my
remar remarks about the difficulties of
imposing a democratic stable order in
Iraq now and I think we will see those
difficulties played out in the coming
days what is of even more interest to us
I think will be the domestic effects of
that that is if the occupation starts to
look bad if there are increasing
political problems if weapons of mass
destruction are not found or very few of
them are found all of this will redound
and and hurt or affect the
administration all of us I think should
remember that we now have a Republican
Party that is absolutely dependent for
its political energy on national
security that is it is dependent on
foreign policy and national security for
its popularity its domestic policies are
very unpopular and indeed 9/11 I think
it is fair to say was an extremely
fortunate event for the Republican Party
and that sounds like an awful thing to
say but the fact is that the Republican
Party came out of the 90s having lost
its key two key issues one in economic
policy that is a balanced budget and
economic fiscal responsibility which had
been destroyed by the Reagan huge Reagan
deficits and by Clinton's successful
pursuit of a balanced budget and high
growth and national security policy
which ended with the Cold War thank you
Mark
not only has time for inspections begun
to run out I'm afraid I'm informed
my overseers that the time for at least
this even modest debate is fast running
can I add one sentence you may add one
sentence and then I want to give both
Samantha and Mr Shearer an opportunity
as well
my one sentence is that to the extent
this looks bad in Iraq will be the
extent those who want to extend this
revolution by force of arms elsewhere
they in the administration they will be
strengthened and that is what we should
keep our eye on in the interest of time
I'm afraid I have to ask you to speak
twice as fast in half the remaining time
Samantha power with me that's a very bad
idea the Federal Express guy the Iran
just a point to respond to to
Christopher I think he's so right about
the revolution that's taken hold there
but I'll hold there but one of these we
have to ask ourselves is isn't that
actually a model for vernacular rising a
process a democratic process one of the
things as you know that the dissidents
and and the heroes of that imminent
counter-revolution one of the positions
they've taken is the United States just
whatever you do don't show up with the
hairy hands of USAID you know don't you
know send us computers don't taint us by
association with your you know project
your imperial project and and if we are
sensitive we will we will not but there
are people within the administration who
are not at all solicitous in fact of the
Democratic impulse of the Democrats
within these societies and I think that
there's a there's a sort of bullying and
a one-size-fits-all temperament that we
have to be very careful but I hope
you're right that we won't go there
but we all have to ask ourselves about
what democracy means I mean the point
was raised about wanting democracy being
wanting our results or the results that
we like and and the president in his
interview with Brokaw said this week my
preference is for church to be separate
from state and that is his preference
it's most of our preferences and we it
the collective challenge is how do we
build not just a democracy where the she
I do go to the poll and do create
another we have to wait another 20 years
for
vernacular ization of that
counter-revolution with with a another
theocratic fetishistic regime how do we
create a liberal democracy and not just
a poll voting democracy and then final
point I hope an important one I think a
lot of this debate has been about a
rocky rocky rack and this replicates
very much I mean it has been that's the
title of the panel it's fair but it
replicates very much the way the Bush
administration I think itself had a
debate about Iraq and it brings a
singular it's a quite typical American
an empire or superpower feature but it
brings an exaggerated or an
unprecedented ala carte ism to the way
it focuses on its foreign policy so it
actually thought that it could have the
debate about whether to go into war in
Iraq whether on human rights grounds or
on disarmament grounds without noting
that the credibility of our arguments
were being was being gauged on the basis
of our policies in other areas so they
didn't see how our position on AIDS
drugs and intellectual property concerns
or on farm subsidies or on climate
change or an International Criminal
Court all of that happened in other
areas we were having a debate within the
four corners of Iraq and unfortunately
other people are judging the legitimacy
of our arguments on a much more lateral
basis not just laterally but also
actually historically thank you very
much Samantha
Robert Scheer this is what ten seconds
of truth okay if you can confine it to
even several haikus together that would
be appreciated well let me give us
several cut haikus I mean I can't do it
as a poet but a we are the strongest
nation that has ever existed in the
world disproportionately more powerful
than any society and we are more
[ __ ] more afraid of our own
people than we've ever been I don't get
it I don't understand why we have
prisoners locked up and they don't have
a right to lawyers I understand why
immigrants have to register I don't
understand why these talk show nuts keep
telling us we can't challenge them I
don't understand where are the advocates
of democracy who are the people who
believe in freedom eight for God's sake
when is there a better time to debate
than when you're thinking about remaking
the whole world you know why shouldn't
you be debating it you know and on every
level we said those scientists in Iraq
should be in an environment where they
could speak freely why are they being
held and why is there not one single
journalist that seems to want to
interview them they've been held since
April 12th the most leading what are
they doing being worked over you know
are they being treated like they're
being in trunk Guantanamo so so the
basic the basic issue here is really not
our right to intervene well I think we
should intervene in the world to stop
genocide I think we should do it with
maximum support of other countries I
think we should do it when it's clear I
think non-proliferation is an important
issue we don't want not to lie about
where nuclear weapons are weapons of
mass destruction we ought to be clear
about it and we ought to act with as
much unity and clarity of purpose to
stop that okay our administration hasn't
done that
it was indifferent to these issues
before September 11th it has exploited
these issues after September 11th for
political reasons and that is dangerous
too dangerous so I would leave here with
one final challenge when you go home and
you listen on your car radio
maybe I'm sensitive because my name
seems to come up every half-hour but you
listen a car radio and you say geez
people really believe in democracy today
really believe in
debate today we really believe that
truth what drives out era and and the
mistaken also Talat aryan societies
including iraq is they wouldn't let
people speak so they went down this
dangerous road or are these people
really these neoconservatives a variant
of the old permanent revolution that
characterized that old left whether it
was Trotsky stone or whatever that they
knew best how to make a better man in a
better world and a better map and by God
a we're going to do it no matter how
much damage it caused because they had
the military strength to do it
a very dangerous posture supported by a
relatively few number of small number of
people in our administration and I
suspect opposed by most of the adult
foreign policy people this country
probably the president's father included
I'd like to as you can see this debate
will continue around water coolers
around coffee tables around dinner
tables and even inside the cranium of
one's own hand ahead as we try to puzzle
out what is the moral course what is the
best course for the Republic how to act
morally in an immoral world thank you
very much for your attention
book TV's coverage of the